there is something about football that
um
has all the elements of a great sport
it's the teamwork
it's the sort of the combat aspect of it
it's like it's the purity of it it's uh
of like
strength and power and speed
and all the elements of like
last minute close calls required to to
win the game
and uh where referee decisions of course
that's essential for a sport can screw
up the whole thing just got all of it
together i think uh just
i don't know it gives the the drama and
the triumphs are just beautiful like
some of my favorite memories i don't
know if it's an accident or this is
common with people
is just with friends watching football
yeah and connecting over that
yeah well it's look it's an incredible
game because there's nowhere to hide
right you're out there on the field it
you know it's uh
it's a great game that requires
not only all those attributes that you
said but it's it's incredibly complex
game so if you don't know what you're
looking at and you don't understand how
complex
defenses are trying to disguise what
they're doing
offenses are trying to overcome that and
and you can set up one play the entire
you know the entire game but a team
that plays well together
right knows their plays inside and out
knows their assignments inside and out
can overcome and beat a more physically
gifted team
because of that uh you know work that
that aspect of working together one of
the things
that i always loved
about sports is just
you're out there
there's a set of rules and there's a
scoreboard
so
at the end of that game it says and you
can make excuses about the refs or this
happened or that happened but
you know at the end of the day
did you go out and compete
and when you went out
and were a competitor
how did it work out
right and and the simplicity of that and
the purity of that
um is something that i always have been
drawn to
what about the business of sort of uh
owning a team or putting together a team
or trying to like build up a team that's
going to be a great team like what are
some interesting aspects that people
might not realize that you can carry
over from
all the other
experience you have in business
i i think the hardest thing about
professional sports right now it's
individuals getting paid money to to
play a sport which is different than
it's certainly different than amateur
and
you know the decisions that are hard
is when you get to know somebody who's a
player on the team
and either they're at the end of their
career or you need to go in a different
direction and that person
who's done everything that you've asked
you know whatever the coaches have asked
of that person and
you get close to them and then
when they when they have to be traded
released or whatever happens it's
you know that's sad and being able to
stand back and in some ways be
dispassionate and not be a fan right
there's a
um i'm on the baseball hall of fame
board
and uh one of the
the guys that's on the the board of me
is jerry reinsdorf and i think it was
jerry who said
you know if you act like a fan you'll be
sitting with them
um which i thought was kind of funny
well i got to push back on that a little
bit
as a by way of a fan asking a dumb
question
okay let me just give some examples i
it's very common in sport it's funny you
said this example of like
certain great players going to another
team right at the end of their career
and uh it always makes me sad it almost
makes me want to wish that you kind of
retired right there
um
from a perspective of just like
d do you ever
as a as an owner but just in that space
think about like
the steelers in the full arc of human
history
so not like as a business i mean okay
this is actually my good news i don't
have to think about it right
you know i'm a minority owner so i can
think about it almost uh as a fan but
i'm sorry go ahead yeah well that's what
i mean i i suppose this is a dumb
question to think of um
like of a business in that way
not just investment but like
like legacy of like what footprint would
you leave on this world right on this
history that is one thing that i can say
unequivocally and i i only have the
experience that i have
but one of the things that i'm so proud
of
um about the way the steelers conduct
themselves is
and that's the rooney family that's the
legacy of the rooney family is asking
constantly about what's right for the
league what's right for the players
you know what what
what's the right thing to do here and
that that's something i would hear mr
rooney say
all the time so i think that legacy is
important because ultimately
the team belongs to that city right
belongs to those fans
and you know the owners are the
custodians of that
so i think
and when you realize what sports teams
mean to the fans the memories that
creates the bonds that it creates
it's a you know it's a responsibility
um
and i i i think that you do have to
think beyond the
you know certainly not just dollars and
cents but just
sports is a very big deal
in our society and and it has to be
i think held to a standard
uh that's not just
well were we profitable this year or
what
that's there are other businesses for
that
it is certainly a business i don't mean
to romanticize to the the point that
it's not but
it to me it's it's more than that or at
least my experience has been that it's
more than that it's a source of meaning
for millions of people
like and you see that most like doing
kovitz for example
when there's so much desperation so
maybe people losing a job so many people
having to deal with the uncertainty what
the future holds that's right there's
something about those sports that just
unites us that again the the the tragedy
and the triumphs
of sport of united of gathering together
with your friends with family shared
experience of over like this yeah over
just
team over rooting for your team for your
city
and the access you know again as i
alluded to
we didn't have anything when i was
growing up but i
would pour through the box scores i was
a huge yankee fan and steeler fan
and feeling some ownership of that right
that i could read the box score and
relive what they did and occasionally
see them on tv
and
feel like i was part of that celebration
when they won and everything it's a very
powerful thing
you